please welcome Her Excellency the right
honorable Mary Simon governor general of
Canada
is
president of the metis National Council
great to see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
pleasure to see you Amira thank you
I like that
yesterday
what a day great to see you guys
Happy Canada Day
hey guys great to see you
again
[Music]
for sure
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
to start off today's festivities let's
take a moment of reflection with our
indigenous communities
led by First Nation inuk and metis
Nation female Elders this unique
teaching recognizes and raises awareness
about our relationship with the land
festivities
foreign
[Applause]
holders the Algonquin the elders
the War veterans the ancestors and
invited guests I am Debbie Sampson the
Schweppes Nation the Adams Lake Indian
band
this land that is known as Canada is a
small part of Turtle Island
that is on Mother Earth this land is
beautiful she is sacred she is The Giver
of Life
the winged ones the finned ones the
four-legged the little creatures that
crawl upon the earth and the two-legged
and the root people are dependent
on the sacred land the water and the air
this land provides shelter food and
medicines we're a family of hunters and
gatherers
we love our wild Meats
our fish our berries
this is who we are this is our way of
life
there are so many gifts to mention
for that of which the sacred lands have
bestowed upon us the mountains the water
the air they are our calm they are our
peace they are our healing and our
medicine away from them we become lost
our hearts hardened and our spirits and
our ancestors cry I have a
responsibility to speak for those who
cannot speak for themselves
the Natural Life In Our Generations to
come so I have to speak of the things
that are happening to Mother Earth there
once was a time that my relatives of the
Natural Life were plentiful and healthy
global warming clear-cut mountains
natural gas oil wells
Minds on the land and on the Seas the
contaminants are destroying and
poisoning the air the waters the land
the effects to the ecosystem are
astronomical
like the people the winged ones the fin
ones the four-legged the little
creatures that crawl upon the Earth
or
are becoming diseased and crowded under
their territories
their numbers are low becoming
endangered
they're becoming more and more scarce as
their homes are destroyed
we're all interconnected we are all
dependents of the Sacred lands I'm
afraid for the generations to come for
what befalls the land the water and the
air the natural life befalls my people
all people
this is a world this is a government
this is an individual issue and
responsibility that we have to the
Creator
to the sacred lands and the generations
to come
if we don't do things differently as a
government as individuals as people
we will not survive
listen to the land our life Giver she is
in pain she cries
as she burns from global warming from
fires she cries as she falls apart from
earthquakes floods and slides listen
love and care for this land
I pray for the land
our life Giver for the future I pray for
forgiveness as we have allowed and
continue to allow greed development and
egos to destroy life
I pray that I have an answer
when it is my time to stand before the
Creator
and he asks with tears in his eyes you
knew you heard you saw what was
happening
what have you done
to care for to love and to protect
your mother the Earth
the Natural Life
what have you done
I pray we all open our eyes
our hearts to the reality and do our
part
the best that we can to help the lands
to heal For the Love of life loves
Mother Earth
love the natural life with that I say
fiction All My Relations
hello neighbor
lunacy welcome everyone
good morning
Charlotte Wolverine
I'm from Charlotte wolfrey I'm Charlie
Wilford from riglet
and I can't talk about the land without
talking about the ice the snow and the
water because that's who we are
do when you eat the land brings food
material for our traditional clothing
material for practicing our traditional
lifestyle
like the holy care which couldn't keep
lighted because of the wind
it also brings healing and inner peace
we are a part of the land our
traditional lifestyle is still alive and
well
when I go out on the land where I live
it is virtually untouched I can walk in
the same paths that my ancestors walked
in
they are still there kept up by the
generations who still hunt fish and
gather from the same places that they
used
years ago my community riglet was just a
trading post
and with an inundated name we call dxo
music and to us it meant a place to
trade
families still lived out on the land and
as a matter of fact I was born out on
the land and my family moved to a
community
a couple of years after I was born which
was in the 1950s
today most families have homesteads or
small cabins built where their ancestors
used to live
before they were relocated
we are still quite nomadic and go
certain places depending on the time of
the year
and we still use tents and travel from
place to place following the seasons and
the food sources
our survival was dependent
on traditional information
passed down from generation to
generation
climate change is changing that
teachings are the lives that we were
taught
and the care that we were told to have
for the land and the environment
contravenes what is happening today
even though we still have a lot of bond
touched land and can still walk those
paths what's happening in the south is
changing our lifestyle and our
Traditions our Winters the ice wind
storms the unexpected heat these are
changing what we do and how we do it
the ice leaves a lot earlier and comes a
lot later this changes our hunting
patterns the winds are harder so we
can't get away from our communities to
go to the places that we go to to heal
and to become one with nature the
berries are being affected by extreme
thunderstorms and dry spells and I
wanted to begin this journey talking
from where we came
and to remind everyone that we sustained
ourselves since time immemorial
and to give a reminder that what happens
in the South affects us in the North
what happens in the big cities with
millions of people affects us in tiny
communities with populations of less
than a thousand people
climate change is changing us as Inuit
our traditional knowledge for example
about the ice conditions that we
followed forever is not necessarily
correct anymore
when we go out on the land to hunt and
fish
when we can't go out on the land to hunt
and fish we will no longer be able to
pass on those skills to our children and
our grandchildren we won't be able to
show them the things that we were taught
this is a reality that we as Inuit are
living with concerned about and worried
about
thank you
foreign
hello my name is Laura Lee Lanz I am a
cookham grandmother with La Femme chip
up to pimsawak women of the metis nation
I reside in a Tuscany also known as
Calgary which is treaty seven territory
in Alberta I want to offer you a
teaching about the metis nation people
and our connection to the land
the metis emerged as a distinct
indigenous people in the 18th century
and our traditional Homeland spans
across several Canadian provinces and
territories including Alberta
Saskatchewan Manitoba parts of Ontario
British Columbia and the Northwest
Territories
we have a deep respect for the land
which has been our foundation provider
and teacher we have learned to live in
harmony with nature respecting the
land's rhythms and Bounty each season
provides different offerings that
sustain us physically and spiritually
the Red River cart is a symbol of our
relationship to the land this simple yet
ingenious cart played a crucial role in
our history allowing us to travel across
the vast and varied terrain of our
homeland drawn by oxen the cart was
essential for survival enabling our
ancestors to transport themselves and
goods across long distances
for us the land is not something to
conquer or to exploit but to respect and
to nurture we understand the delicate
balance between taking from the land and
giving back to it we listen to the land
The Whispers The Echoes the melody and
sometimes the silence
we observe the land its beauty its
offerings its pain and struggles
we live in harmony with nature and
recognize the interconnection between
all living beings and Mother Earth
we use the land's offerings in a
sustainable manner ensuring those gifts
are Everlasting when harvesting berries
we leave some behind for the other
beings that rely on them
when Gathering plants medicines and
sacred items we take them with gentle
hands leaving enough for the plants to
regenerate and thrive
if we hunt an animal for food we use all
parts of the animal for food clothing
tools and art
by caring for and nurturing the land we
show gratitude and respect to Mother
Earth we know that our well-being is
tied to the health and the strength of
the land
in today's world as our Earth faces
unprecedented environmental challenges
we can all learn from these metis
teachings and wisdom
we should listen
observe and connect with the land
understanding its sacredness and our
responsibility to protect it
the land and our connection to it are
important to our identity as people of
the metis nation I hope this teaching
has given you a renewed awareness and
respect for the land consider reflecting
on your own connection to the land that
you walk upon and how you can become a
guardian to the left to the Earth let us
work together to protect honor and
preserve the planet for the well-being
of all and future Generations Marcy High
height
foreign
guests today are honored to become
Canadian citizens
some have been waiting years for this
opportunity and to have their ceremony
happen on Canada Day makes the
experience even more memorable and
impactful
Cameroon
but today they will officially become
Canadians
thank you
Canada
a distance
[Music]
[Applause]
great to see everybody
[Music]
from Canada
[Applause]
my name is Rebecca mcconan it is my
pleasure to welcome you to the Canada
Day celebration in the nation's capital
performance the Tyler Shaw is
Alex Carlos no
news
is ceremony
[Music]
and on top of that let me tell you that
40 of the volunteers that contribute to
these Canada Day Celebrations were born
outside of Canada and originate from 39
different countries and today we'll make
history as 17 candidates will also
become Canadian citizens by the end of
our broadcast
and as they continue on their Journey
let us reflect on our journey as
Citizens as Canadians and as the people
who make this the country what it is
while laying a foundation for what it
will be available
is
on this day 100 years ago Canada passed
the Chinese Immigration Act which
effectively banned Chinese immigrants
from entry into Canada for almost 24
years
taking the time to acknowledge the
devastating effects of closing our
borders based on race or nationality 100
years ago
straightens our resolved today to
Champion inclusivity and embrace new
immigrants from all over the world with
open arms
[Applause]
one of the most influential Canadian
artists of the 20th century is
in France
[Music]
resilience
this is how we connect and this is the
day we celebrate those connections from
coast to coast to coast
hello
[Applause]
she's an impassioned advocate for
indigenous rights and has presided over
1600 citizenship ceremonies please
welcome judge Suzanne carrier
foreign
[Music]
moments the 17 of you will become
Canadian citizens
is
citizens of this great nation you get to
enjoy incredible rights and privileges
Royal
you have the right to equality
regardless of your race gender religion
or sexual orientation Embrace this right
and promote a society that respects and
values the uniqueness of each individual
you have the right to freedom of speech
allowing you to express your thoughts
and opinions without fear
this Freedom gives voice to your ideas
enabling you to actively participate in
shaping the future of our society
is
religion
the permit under Swift observation
is
but as I'm sure you're aware Canadian
citizenship does come with
responsibilities as well
the responsibility
you have the responsibility to respect
and obey the laws of Canada upholding
these laws Fosters a just Society
ensuring peace and harmony for everyone
you have the responsibility to learn
about historical wrongs committed
against indigenous peoples and to
actively engage in the process of
healing and Reconciliation
for many indigenous people this day in
particular is a painful reminder of this
country's Colonial history and of
ongoing systemic injustices
let us build bridges of understanding
and solidarity and dedicate ourselves to
creating a Canada that truly embodies
equality Justice and respect for all
responsibilities
foreign
a diverse and vibrant tapestry of
individuals who proudly call themselves
Canadians embrace the rights and
responsibilities that come with this
privilege and let us continue building a
better brighter future for Canada
I can't wait to see all that we can
accomplish together
um
please welcome the minister of Canadian
Heritage
Pablo Rodriguez
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa hey Canada
George carias thank you so much for that
introduction what a great start thank
you Tyler merci beaucoup
you guys are beautiful look at you
you're beautiful look at all the people
around you because
and honestly
honestly I can't think of a better way
to welcome the group of new canaans with
us today
because that's the spirit of our country
it's about being able to say no matter
where you're from how old you are
or who you love
Canada is your home Canada is your home
usually
um
opportunity
foreign
and today
my friends
we're sharing this moment with you
Canada Day
will always be special to you because
this this is the day this country are
foolishly becomes your home
so
today's party is for you guys huh you
have thousands of people here today to
tell you welcome to your home we're all
here for you
welcome to your home
felicitations
[Applause]
Canada
is
and I see such an amazing amazing
diversity of people coming together to
celebrate what it means to be Canadian
to celebrate there are differences are
the very things that make us stronger
to celebrate King incredible Canadian
artists who connect us
to celebrate our culture our values
to celebrate each other
because this is what Canada is all about
it's about you it's about you it's about
you and you it's about all of you
because Canada
lives in your heart Kevin lives in the
heart of its people so let's hear your
hearts shine Canada that's your pride
shine bonfire to Canada happy Canada day
everyone
foreign
[Music]
all right so this is it the moment
you've been waiting for the swearing of
the Oaths of citizenship
linguistic Duality is an integral part
of our Canadian identity and a
fundamental value of our country and so
we will swear the oath in English and
then in French
let's reality language ticket and part C
anything around Delhi dance
with the candidates for citizenship
please stand and raise your right hand
they can't die last train too
is
at this time we invite everyone else to
stand raise their right hand and repeat
the oath if you wish it's a
demonstration of your commitment to
Canada but it will not make you a
Canadian if you are not one already
foreign
I swear
that I'll be faithful
and bear true allegiance
to his majesty
King Charles III King George Third King
of Canada
his heirs and successors
and that I will Faithfully observe
the laws of Canada
including the Constitution
which recognizes and affirms
the Aboriginal and treaty rights
of First Nations of First Nations Inuit
and metis peoples
and fulfill my duties
as a Canadian citizen
excellent one more time in French
Francis
[Applause]
majestyles constitutions
[Music]
you did it congratulations everyone
Welcome to our Canadian Canadian Emily
felization
[Applause]
is
[Music]
and now it's my pleasure to welcome and
introduce a man who's about to take a
giant step also as the Canadian crew
member on the Artemis 2 mission please
welcome
Canadian space agency astronaut Colonel
Jeremy Hansen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here on this
special day Jeremy
oh it's a pleasure to be here and I have
to say congratulations for everyone here
is experiencing Canada day as new
citizens uh welcome to Canada yeah
welcome to Canada in 2024 Canada will
make history when the Artemis 2 crew
flies around the moon for the first
crude flight since the Apollo missions
over 50 years ago what does it mean to
you to be part of such a historic event
Jeremy
well it's an unbelievable honor this is
the first crude Test Flight of the
Artemis program which is a multi-mission
campaign and our goal is to create a
sustainable lunar presence and pave the
way for human exploration of Mars what
are you most looking forward to
well to start I'm excited about working
with my fellow NASA colleagues Reed
Wiseman Victor Glover and Christina cook
three people for whom I have incredible
professional and personal respect as we
take on this challenge together
I'm also excited about the perspective
of witnessing an earthrise the
breathtaking view of our planet
suspended against the Blackness of space
from the perspective of the Moon and I
am personally grateful for this
opportunity and I know it's going to
serve as an important reminder of our
individual responsibility to take care
of our precious home but I have to tell
you most importantly to me I'm humbled
to showcase the incredible work of so
many Canadians that earned our place in
these Artemis Artemis missions
I want you to understand your work
inspires me if Canada can fly to the
moon imagine what we can do next I am so
incredibly proud of you Canada
[Music]
sure you are of course you are set
missions
Generations mama
keep
foreign
thank you so much for having me and
thank you Canada for continuing to dream
big
I love the energy here and now as I look
forward to venturing beyond the confines
of Earth it is my great pleasure to
introduce a man whose aim it is to guide
our nation towards New Frontiers and who
has shaped how Canada leverages space to
maximize its benefits here on Earth
please join me in welcoming the right
honorable prime minister
Le Train Arab Justin Trudeau
thank you
[Music]
together today
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Canada Day Canada
Jeremy I want to start by thanking you
for your introduction but most of all
I want to thank you for inspiring us all
in the coming year as the first Canadian
ever who will travel to the Moon
performance
today marks the
156th anniversary of our great country
some of you have ancestors that were
here way before Confederation and some
of you arrived more recently like the
new Canadian citizens we just welcomed
Anthony Armel
silvi Alex
or Joshua Ralph Jessica
Rana Hala Ibrahim
Youssef Jude Ghazal
Canada is now officially your home
welcome my friends
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
my friends the world and our country are
facing incredible challenges right now
War has returned to Europe climate
change is making extreme weather like
wildfires floods and hurricanes even
worse inflation although it is getting
better is still putting real stress on
families but no matter the challenges we
Face we will get through it the same way
we always do by staying true to our
values
[Applause]
values like justice openness and
democracy that's Canada's advantage in
the world now more than ever
refers
foreign
thank you to all the workers who are
powering our economy from delivering
energy to Canadians to making clean tech
and clean steel around the world
thank you to the members of the Canadian
Armed Forces who put their lives on the
line to protect our citizens and our
values at home and abroad
and in this Smoky Ottawa air thank you
to the First Responders and brave
firefighters including friends from
around the world who are right now
keeping our communities safe in these
difficult times
you know last week
I had the honor of meeting two Canadian
heroes Captain Kevin corcram and
firefighter Connor Scott who serve in
the Halifax Regional fire and Emergency
Services when they got a call about a
man who is home inside the danger zone
They didn't hesitate they jumped in a
pickup truck and drove through a wall of
fire to save that man's life
[Music]
when I met them
they were wearing their firefighter
uniforms with the Canadian flag on it
and I thought to myself these guys with
their courage and their humility embody
the very best of what the maple leaf
represents for us all
Canada
throughout history people have looked to
Canada as an amazing place but
increasingly now people are coming to
Canada to proudly call it their home and
build their lives and our communities
and our country all together and that's
why today we celebrate the fact that
Canada now counts 40 million people
although
given the citizenship ceremony we just
had we're now at least 40 million and
17. congratulations guys
[Applause]
foreign
I think of
Kamali power of rainbow railroad who was
born and raised in Canada by
jamaican-born parents Kamali now works
to help
2slgbtqi plus refugees Escape violence
and persecution around the world and
brings them to safety here in Canada
every day Canadians of diverse Origins
are enriching and shaping our
communities from coast to coast to coast
Canada has the fastest growing
population among industrialized
economies and we're the second fastest
growing economy in the G7
continent
and let's continue making sure that all
of our children know that here everyone
can follow their dreams even if those
dreams are to follow in the footsteps of
Jeremy Hansen and go to the Moon because
in Canada with hope and hard work
everything is possible
[Applause]
happy Canada day everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
so let us continue to unearth and
embrace the stories past and present of
all who call Canada home so that we can
be better allies neighbors and Friends
Simon
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
minister
elders
ministers dignitaries and dear guests
and new citizens that were just honored
today
thank you so much to join to everyone
joining us here today as We Gather on
the unseated territory of the Algonquin
anishnabi people who have lived on and
cared for this land for thousands of
years
while you have heard other land
acknowledgments these words are
important to show gratitude to
indigenous peoples for welcoming us to
their lands and acknowledge Canada's
true history
samoso reconciliation
reconciliation is not an indigenous
issue
it's a Canadian issue
nor is reconciliation
one act or one moment
many simple small acts contribute to the
process of reconciliation to inclusion
inclusion is a powerful word it's about
being seen being heard
feeling like you matter
like you are represented
across Canada I can see we are making
progress in Building Bridges and
renewing relationships between different
peoples All Peoples one act at a time
part two of Canada
jacons
Faith the program Act
I love for
I have seen it in the Northwest
Territories where volunteers from food
secured rescue Yellowknife are working
alongside grocery stores to bring food
which would otherwise be thrown away to
those in the greatest need
I have seen it in Quebec in Alberta in
British Columbia in Nova Scotia
in communities new too numerous to list
as wildfires rage and flooding impacts
homes and livelihoods
firefighters and volunteers from across
Canada and around the world are fighting
side by side protecting communities
people and nature
and I have seen it in Winnipeg at the
Ukrainian Cultural and education center
where volunteers are helping refugees to
rebuild their lives here in Canada and
to learn English
they're also helping to preserve their
Ukrainian culture and language so they
can stay connected to who they are
and all that they have left behind
we need to find ways to learn from each
other
and about each other
I'm proud to live in a country that is
actively working to overcome the
challenges that stand in the way of our
progress
a country that is focused on the
national and Global issues that impact
us every day
God is striving to be diverse open and
accepting a country where we can one day
be free to be who we are without
judgment
where new citizens can feel completely
at home in Canada encouraged to help
shape our future
where traditional indigenous knowledge
is used and respected alongside
scientific knowledge to advance research
conservation and Reconciliation
where members of our Canadian Armed
Forces can continue to serve with honor
and courage
where Canadians
learn about the mistakes of our past to
make sure we don't repeat them again in
our future
where people engage in their communities
and advocate for the most vulnerable
Among Us
if we have the hard conversations
if we put in the hard work
if we do so together
there is nothing that we cannot do
let us make the choice
choose to listen and learn
choose respect and understanding
choose to take the hands of friendship
and support
choose to look for the good among us and
within us
believe in each other as I believe in
you
despo
so happy Canada day everybody born fed
to Canada
thank you merci
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome back
thank you
to our newest Canadians congratulations
once again and welcome home it was an
honor and a privilege to be part of this
ceremony with you today and I thank you
from the bottom of my heart Mike is
you'll now be singing O Canada for the
very first time as Canadian citizens
this is now your national anthem so sing
it with pride attackers
please rise for our national anthem
[Music]
thank you
Oh Canada
[Music]
he lost it
glorious
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
[Applause]